Retomando el video anterior, creo que ya
tenemos una idea razonablemente buena de
qué tan grande es el Sol respecto a la Tierra y
de qué tan lejos está la Tierra del Sol. Además,
ya sabemos que la mayoría de los diagramas que
hemos visto en los libros de texto no hacen
justicia. De hecho, cuando vimos este Sol de
aquí, que era de unos 15 centímetros de ancho,
dije que la Tierra sería un punto diminuto, pero
no estaría a esta distancia, sino a 15 metros a la
derecha o a la izquierda del Sol, es decir,
su órbita tendría un radio de unos 15 metros,
por lo que ni siquiera la percibiríamos si la
intentamos ver desde aquí, sería una pequeña
partícula orbitando a esta enorme distancia.
Si miras este Sol aquí, si pudiéramos dibujar
todo este Sol, tendría un diámetro de unos 50
centímetros; en esta situación, esta Tierra de
aquí que sí está dibujada a escala, esta Tierra
no estaría ni con mucho así de cerca, estaría a
unos 60 metros en esa dirección. Podemos imaginar
que si el Sol fuese de este tamaño y estuviera
situado en un campo de fútbol, este pequeño punto
que es la Tierra, esta pequeña partícula de aquí,
estaría a unos 60 metros de distancia, tan pequeña
que ni la notarías. Quizá te darías cuenta de ella
a una cierta distancia, pero no serías capaz de
ver esta partícula desde allí. Y algunos de los
otros planetas están aún más lejos. Ojo, no todos
los planetas, obviamente tienes a Mercurio por
aquí. Creo que la mayoría estamos familiarizados
con los nombres de los planetas del Sistema Solar,
pero los nombraré por si acaso, este es Mercurio,
este es Venus, Mercurio es el planeta más pequeño
que no se debate que sea un planeta. Plutón
es el más pequeño, pero hay un debate acerca
si realmente es un planeta o sólo otro tipo
de cuerpo solar grande o un planeta enano o
cualquiera de esas cosas. Aquí está Venus, que es
el de tamaño más similar a la Tierra. Después está
Marte y después está Júpiter. Sólo para tener una
perspectiva de qué tan lejos están estas cosas,
si volvemos en la analogía de que este es el
tamaño del Sol, entonces Júpiter estaría cinco
veces más lejos que la Tierra, por lo que estaría
-si tenemos una escala-, estaría a 300 metros de
distancia. Por lo que si tenemos un bonito Sol
un poco más grande que un balón de básquetbol,
entonces tendríamos que poner a Júpiter más
pequeño que una pelota de ping pong y tres campos
de fútbol más lejos, así de lejos hasta júpiter.
Y entonces Saturno está 2 veces más lejos, Saturno
está a 9 veces la distancia de la Tierra al Sol.
Vamos a aclarar esto: la Tierra sabemos que está
a una unidad astronómica del Sol aproximadamente.
Recuerda que su distancia cambia porque su órbita
no es perfectamente circular. Júpiter está a
un poco más de 5 unidades astronómicas, o sea,
un poco más de 5 veces la distancia entre el Sol
y la Tierra. Y Saturno está a aproximadamente 9
unidades astronómicas, es decir está a 9 veces la
distancia entre el Sol y la Tierra, por lo que,
otra vez, estos serían aproximadamente 9 campos de
fútbol. Otra manera de pensarlo es que si tenemos
al Sol del tamaño de un balón de básquetbol,
entonces este pequeño Saturno más pequeño que
una pelota de ping pong estaría a 1 kilómetro de
distancia. Y quiero volver a mencionar esto porque
nunca lo visualizamos realmente de esta manera.
Para poder dibujar el Sistema Solar en una página,
vemos diagramas parecidos a este que no está
en un sentido real de qué tan pequeños son
los planetas con respecto al Sol y mucho menos
de sus distancias al Sol. Después está Urano y
más allá Neptuno. Obviamente estos están aún más
lejos. Y todo esto es sólo para darnos una idea,
ya que es muy fácil comenzar a hablar de galaxias
y el universo, pero quiero que entendamos que
estamos hablando de distancias muy grandes y a una
gran escala. Y recuerda: dijimos que tardaríamos
17 años viajando en avión desde la Tierra al
Sol. Ahora, si lo multiplicamos esto por 5,
nos da unos 100 años para ir del Sol a Júpiter
y 200 años para ir hasta Saturno. Si Abraham
Lincoln se hubiera subido a un avión para ir desde
Saturno hasta el Sol, todavía no habría llegado,
es decir, son distancias enormes. Pero aún no
hemos terminado con el Sistema Solar. Para seguir
teniendo una idea de la escala, si este de aquí es
el Sol y, bueno, cada uno de estos planetas es más
angosto que estas órbitas que tenemos dibujadas,
es decir, tenemos dibujadas las órbitas pero en
esta escala no somos capaces de ver los planetas.
Ahora bien, esta es una unidad astronómica, las
distancias del Sol a la Tierra, aquí está Marte
y por acá tenemos este cinturón de asteroides,
el cual también tiene cosas bastante grandes,
tiene estas cosas consideradas casi planetas
enanos, tiene cosas como seres. Y puedes consultar
más sobre estas cosas si te interesa. Entonces,
Júpiter está aquí. Y una vez más, ya hemos dicho
que tardaríamos aproximadamente 100 años en avión
para ir de Júpiter al Sol, pero incluso si
tomamos toda esta caja de aquí, que es una
cantidad enorme de distancia, aproximadamente
unas 5 unidades astronómicas, la luz tardaría
unos 40 minutos para ir desde el Sol hasta
Júpiter. Entonces esta es una distancia enorme,
gigante. Pero aún así podemos poner esta distancia
en esta pequeña caja de aquí, es decir, esta caja
completa de aquí se puede ajustar dentro de esta
pequeña caja en este otro diagrama. Y necesitamos
hacer esto para poder apreciar las órbitas de los
planetas exteriores. En esta escala las órbitas de
la Tierra, Venus, Mercurio y Marte ni siquiera se
pueden diferenciar del Sol, están demasiado cerca,
parece como si fueran partes del Sol cuando las
miras en esta otra escala. Y entonces tenemos los
planetas exteriores: Saturno, Urano, Neptuno; y
además tenemos el Cinturón de Kuiper, que son más
asteroides, pero éstos están congelados. Ya sabes,
cuando pensamos en hielo normalmente pensamos en
agua helada, pero aquí hace tanto frío y cada
vez es más oscuro porque estamos bastante lejos
del Sol, que cosas que normalmente asociamos como
gases van a estar en su estado sólido por aquí,
por lo que no habrán sólo elementos rocosos sino
que también habrá cosas que normalmente asociamos
con gases como el metano pero congelados, metano
congelado. Pero aún aquí no hemos terminado,
aún no estamos fuera del Sistema Solar, y de hecho
vamos a darnos una idea de la escala que estamos
operando. Aquí tengo un diagrama de la misión
Voyager. Las misiones Voyager, Voyager 1 y 2,
de hecho Voyager 2 parte un poco antes, un mes
antes, mientras que Voyager 1 viajaba un poco
más rápido. Estas dos misiones partieron casi un
año después de que yo naciera, y sus velocidades
actuales, para darnos cuenta de qué tan rápido
van son: el Voyager 1, que está justo aquí,
ahora está viajando a unos 61,000 kilómetros por
hora, esos son unos 17 kilómetros por segundo,
es decir, la distancia de una ciudad cada segundo.
Va así de rápido, al menos en mi mente esa es una
velocidad increíblemente rápida. Ese Voyager
está viajando aproximadamente así de rápido,
de hecho, ha pasado alrededor de los planetas y ha
ganado aceleración al pasar cerca de sus órbitas,
pero la mayor parte del tiempo ha ido a una gran
velocidad, una velocidad enorme, gigantesca,
y así ha sido desde 1977. Yo en ese entonces
estaba aprendiendo a caminar y esto ya iba
a estas súper velocidades. Y quiero decir que
durante toda nuestra vida, cuando dormimos en
cualquier momento, cuando comemos, cuando iba
al colegio, esta cosa seguía yendo disparada
hacia fuera del Sistema Solar a esta velocidad. Su
velocidad ha cambiado un poco, pero especialmente
una vez que pasó en los planetas se ha mantenido
a esta velocidad, por lo que está viajando y no,
no me gustaría decir solamente, pero he llegado
hasta acá. Si lo vemos en este diagrama,
ha llegado hasta acá, lo cual equivale más o menos
a unas 115 o 116 unidades astronómicas. Y para
darnos una idea, hay dos maneras de pensar esto.
Una es decir "Guau, eso es muy lejos", porque si
nos damos cuenta que a esta escala no se puede ni
ver la órbita de la Tierra, entonces esta parece
una gran distancia. Y para tener una perspectiva
de qué tanto son 116 unidades astronómicas,
si hace 2,000 años Jesús se hubiera subido un
avión. Por aquí he colocado una imagen de Jesús
para ayudarnos a visualizarlo. Si Jesús se hubiera
subido a un jet y hubiera viajado a unos 1,000
kilómetros por hora en esta dirección, es decir,
en la dirección del Voyager, entonces apenas
ahora el Voyager lo estaría alcanzando. Estas son
distancias enormes, enormes, gigantescas, pero al
mismo tiempo, aunque sea una distancia gigantesca,
sobre todo respecto a las cosas de las que hemos
estado hablando hasta ahora, si pensamos esta
distancia en relación con las regiones exteriores
del Sistema Solar, aún hablamos en términos de una
escala pequeña. Para tener una idea de la escala,
esta caja entera que tenemos aquí cabe dentro de
esta caja, y cuando miras a esta caja, el Voyager
sólo ha llegado hasta aquí después de viajar a
esta increíble velocidad durante más de 30 años,
unos 33 años. Y bueno, para darnos una idea de
estas otras cosas, Sedna que está aquí es un
objeto muy grande del exterior del Sistema
Solar, es uno de los objetos más lejanos
que conocemos del Sistema Solar, y tiene una
órbita muy excéntrica, por lo que se acerca,
no quiero decir relativamente cerca, pero al menos
no excesivamente lejos, y después se desplaza muy
lejos del Sol. Pero incluso la órbita de Sedna,
si la miramos en esta caja de aquí, incluso esta
caja que tenemos aquí puede caber justo acá,
en este nuevo diagrama de aquí, ni siquiera
serías capaz de ver qué tan lejos ha viajado el
Voyager en 33 años a 61,000 kilómetros por hora,
sería un puntito, no serías capaz de percibir
esta distancia. Y aunque no puedas percibir esa
distancia, aún estamos bajo la influencia del Sol,
la atracción gravitacional todavía actúa y atrae
cosas. Y esto de aquí creemos que es la Nube de
Oort, aquí es de donde se originan los cometas.
Éstos son un montón de... podrías verlo como gases
congelados y partículas de hielo y cosas así, pero
apenas estamos comenzando a llegar a las regiones
exteriores del Sistema Solar. Esta distancia de
aquí son 50,000 unidades astronómicas, y
para tener una idea de esta escala, porque
escucharemos mucho de años luz y todo eso, un año
luz son 63,000 unidades astronómicas, es decir,
si viajamos un año luz desde el Sol, entonces
llegarías a la Nube de Oort, la hipotética Nube
de Oort. Y para tener una idea mejor de la escala
de la Nube de Oort, bueno, de hecho sabemos que la
mayoría de planetas orbitan en el mismo plano.
Estas de aquí son las órbitas de los planetas.
Y de nuevo estas líneas están dibujadas demasiado
gruesas, las han dibujado lo más delgadas posibles
para que las podamos ver, pero aún así son
demasiado gruesas. Y todo esto nos lleva hasta
el Cinturón de Kuiper. Pero todo esto que tenemos
aquí, todo lo que hemos visto hasta el Cinturón
de Kuiper, todo hasta los planetas mayores
-esta de aquí es la órbita de Plutón-, todo
este diagrama estaría incluido justo aquí, casi ni
se puede ver. Todo este diagrama es sólo un punto,
y justo aquí puedes ver la Nube de Oort alrededor,
casi como una nube esférica. Creemos que existe,
porque obviamente es muy difícil observar cosas
a esta distancia. En fin, espero que esto nos
comience a dar un poco de perspectiva de la escala
del Sistema Solar, y lo que realmente te va a
asombrar, si es que todo esto no te ha asombrado
lo suficiente, es que todas estas cosas van a
comenzar a aparecer diminutas si comenzamos a
mirar tan sólo la región local de nuestra galaxia,
y mucho más si miramos el universo en su conjunto.
De cualquier manera, esto empieza a alocarse.